NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY "SCARE
B.N.B."
AIRBNB.COM IS A GREAT RESOURCE
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT ALL THE
DISCOMFORT OF NOT STAYING IN A
HOTEL,
COMBINED WITH ALL OF THE FEAR
OF SLEEPING NEAR STRANGERS.
PEOPLE LIST THEIR ACTUAL HOMES
AND THEN PEOPLE THEY
DON'T KNOW COME AND STAY THERE.
IT'S LIKE GOLDILOCKS WITH
PAYPAL.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A PICTURE
FROM AN AIR B.N.B. LISTING
AND I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME A LINE
FROM YOUR REVIEW AFTER
STAYING THERE. HERE'S THE FIRST
ONE.
THIS COZY SUITE THAT SHARES
GROUND WITH A FOX NAMED RABIES
AND SOME CREEPY ART
INSTALLATIONS.
>> HARD TO ( BLEEP ) WHEN
OMINOUS CHILDDEN'S LAUGHTER
BEGINS AT MIDNIGHT.
POINT!
THIS ONE IS IN SEOUL, AND IT
LOOKS LIKE A PRISON CAMP.
NATASHA.
>> EASILY THE NICEST SHOERACK
I'VE EVER SLEPT IN.
ALSO, I HEART THE SMELL OF
KIMCHI FARTS.
>> THIS IS FINE BUT THE MAIDS
WORE WHITE LAB COATS AND THE
FREE BREAKFAST WAS AT THE END OF
A MAZE.
POINTS.
THIS CREEPY ROOM RENTED BY THIS
NOT-AT-ALL-CREEPY GUY.
>> HA-HA-- GOT YOU PREGNANT.
>> MARC.
>> REASONABLE RATES BUT I GOT
TIRED OF PUTTING THE LOTION IN
THE BASKET.
( APPLAUSE )
>> POINTS.
>> HE CALLS IT A DETACHED
SHACK-TEAU.
THE ROOM IS VERY SPACIOUS WHICH
IS NICE, BECUASE THE SMILING
LUNATIC NEVER LEAVES THE ROOM.
>> HE JUST HANGS OUT WITH YOU.
>> "YOU WANT ME TO WAKE YOU UP
AT ANY TIME."
THE OTHER PART OF THAT PICTURE
IS HIS HALF OF THE BED
IT LOOKS LIKE A SMALL BED, BUT
THAT'S LITERALLY--
>> HAD A GREAT STAY UNTIL MY
UNBORN CHILD WAS RIPPED FROM MY
WOMB AS I SLEPT
>> CLOSE TO SUBWAY.
>> POINTS.